[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
en bourgogne et en franche comté pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique nous sommes à prissé au coeur
de la saint vincent tournante du cru
saint véran et c'est l'occasion de nous
pencher sur la vie des territoires
viticoles
il y en a beaucoup en bourgogne et en
franche-comté détention des territoires
sur lesquels sont apparus des tensions
nouvelles des tensions entre habitants
de ces villages parfois et vignerons et
puis des initiatives aussi pour mieux
vivre ensemble pour en parler et pour
essayer de comprendre avec nous ce matin
kevin teyssieu bonjour bonjour
un merci spécial à vous parce que vous
êtes le président de cette saint-vincent
tournante ultra occupé donc mais on
avait vraiment envie de vous avoir parce
qu'une saint-vincent c'est vraiment un
moment d'union va en parler de
rencontres dans les villages
denis thomas bonjour vous êtes
conseiller départemental de côte-d'or
dans le canton de mur saura porter aux
affaires viticole et vous avez vous
aussi connu une saint vincent et c'était
ce livre en 2001 c'était un morceau
marine pasquier bonjour vous avez fondé
le collectif mâconnais pesticides et
santé et sept au coeur bien sûr de notre
sujet du jour et jean michel aubinel
bonjour vous êtes président de la cnbb
qui regroupe toutes les appellations
viticoles de bourgogne
et puis vous êtes viticulteurs a pris
c'est aussi je suis dans mon village est
en plein aussi dans l'organisation de la
saint vincent
ils font un point de départ ce sera pour
nous mais 2016 avec une sorte de faits
divers des menaces pour un responsables
viticoles du mâconnais à cause de
traitement de la vigne bio de là quand
on cherche on s'aperçoit vite c'est un
problème qu'on trouve dans toute la
france
ma première question c'est pourquoi
maintenant pourquoi on a envie d'en
parler maintenant
jean michel aubinel vous être
responsable syndical qui vivaient ici
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de on va dire
néo ruraux
parce qu'aujourd'hui les traitements
chimiques font peur ou parce que le
monde viticole n'y a pas fait attention
avant je crois que déjà c'est vrai que
nos villages évolué on le voit en se
promenant c'est vrai que je dirais que
beaucoup de nos concitoyens ont essayé
de venir s'installer justement dans ces
paysages ces territoires qui sont plus
tôt
beau intéressant à habiter malgré tout
et c'est territoire c'est également un
outil de travail pour nous et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on se trouve confronté
je dirais à de nouvelles attentes de la
part des citoyens c'est très sociétale
en ce moment ce qui se passe et nous
n'étions peut-être pas préparé jusqu'à
présent je crois que nos pratiques
évoluent de toute façon hier nous avions
un défilé nous avons défilé pendant 2 km
dans le vignoble les vignes était verte
en cette saison
quand je dis qu'elle était verte c'est
la terre qui était pas ce qui avait de
l'herbe
il ya trente ans la kul la seule couleur
qui lui ont réussi c'est bien évidemment
donc on va on va bien sûr et venir
marine parce qu'ils se disaient beaucoup
de néo ruraux dans les villages c'est
quoi c'est ça c'est aussi la peur
aujourd'hui des produits chimiques c'est
ce qui agite aussi votre votre mouvement
oui la peur des produits chimiques mais
cette peur elle est vraiment justifiée
c'est vrai que maintenant je pense que
le les gens et les consommateurs en
particulier sont beaucoup plus exigeants
et puis
tout simplement les maladies commencent
à exploser donc ça interpelle ses
intérêts
kevin teyssieu vous vous êtes vignerons
ici vous n'êtes pas ici du monde
viticole en même temps à l'origine alors
quel regard vous portez sur sur le sujet
dont on dont on parle aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que c'est ça regard un peu plus
large puisque moi j'ai été plus
sensibilisés sur notion de développement
durable tous secteurs d'activité
confondus et aujourd'hui je découvre
uniquement là la problématique là
prometic phytosanitaires et est ce qui
est intéressant c'est justement avec ce
nouveau regard d'essayer d'apporter
quelque chose de plus globale essayer de
penser à 6 notion de traitement mais
aussi ses notions de de travail à la
vigne ces questions sociales ces
questions économiques comment on peut
essayer effectivement de s'arranger tout
ça donc voilà c'est peut-être ce regard
nouveau que je peux avoir avec ce recul
et cette expérience sur cette notion
plus globale de développement durable
denis thomas vous êtes rapporteurs des
affaires viticole vous en côte d'or au
conseil départemental
vous êtes élu de morceaux mais vous
n'êtes pas vigneron ce dont on parle à
ce sujet il était en germe en réalité
depuis un certain temps dans les
villages du monde viticole dans les
villages et dans les collectivités
il faut bien le souligner vous savez la
côte d'or je parle sous le contrôle de
jean michel aubinel c'est 1290 domaine
viticole c'est 4500 emplois c'est
également dix mille hectares sur la côte
d'or donc c'est vrai qu'à une prise de
conscience prise de conscience de ce
phénomène qui aujourd'hui est
d'actualité et je suis persuadé
d'actualité aujourd'hui ça veut dire
qu'à une époque
en gros on s'en fichait même si l'eau
des sources étaient parfois polluer même
s'ils ont finalement il y a eu des
pratiques culturales pour y évoluer
il y a aussi des pratiques
environnementales qui se développe
si je prends l'exemple du département de
la côte d'or le président sauvadet
viennent mettre en place un programme
pour les cinq ans qui viennent sur
futures 21 qui va protéger la forêt qui
va protéger les rivières les eaux qui va
protéger la viticulture
donc il ya tout un tout un levier today
tout un levier qui va permettre
justement d'être dans une dans une
dimension très respectueuse de
l'environnement
jean michel aubinel c'est vous disiez on
s'y étaient pas préparés ou
avait pas vu venir en fait pendant
longtemps les professionnels du monde
viticole il était un peu seul sur leur
territoire finalement en tout cas il en
avait la sensation
c'est vrai qu'on était seul sur nos
territoires et en même temps peut être
prisonnier de nos actes de production de
notre devoir de produire et l'actualité
ne générer ne se faisait pas que il y
avait une réelle prise de conscience
effectivement de tout ce qui pouvait
générer des nuisances des pollutions etc
aujourd'hui encore une fois je crois que
nous sommes comme tout le monde avant
tout des femmes et des hommes dans nos
vignobles
nous nous sommes sensibles justement à
toutes ces problématiques de santé etc
et nous sommes les premiers à vouloir
évoluer nous adapter également aux
nouvelles demandes ont nouvelles
attentes des soucier d'eux des citoyens
le citoyen dont je parlais tout à
l'heure j'ai utilisé le mot fait du vert
marine pasquet avec ce qui s'était passé
comment vous vous êtes reçus on va dire
est ce que votre lutte intéresse
beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui est ce
qu'il ya une vraie sensibilité à ces
sujets dans l'est dans les villages ah
oui totalement
je pense que il ya énormément de gens
qui se sentaient seuls qui rencontraient
des problèmes qui nous est pas forcément
aller parler à leurs voisins
viticulteurs en gros c'est quoi c'est la
personne qui est dans son jardin puis
qui voit quelqu'un qui traite à côté et
qui sait pas trop comment lui dire où
qui qu'à un peu peur de ce qui se passe
c'est ça on peut le dire comme ça
oui parce que c'est des problèmes par
exemple de pulvérisation de gouttelettes
qui arrive jusqu'à sur les six que
jusque sur les fenêtres par exemple des
gens ou des parents d'enfants qui sont
dans les écoles dans les crèches à
proximité des vignes et le fait qu'on
soit regroupé ça les aide aussi à
pouvoir exprimer des problèmes et alors
ça se résume pas qu'aux produits
phytosanitaires
finalement il ya aussi il ya d'autres
sujets par exemple développement de
l'oenotourisme ça fait que vous faites
venir des gens dans les villages qui ne
connaissent pas forcément bien le monde
viticole kevin teyssieu et ça aussi ça
veut dire qu'il faut en tenir compte
maintenant oui c'est ça c'est une
nouvelle économie qui se met en place
c'est effectivement un territoire qui
accueille des visiteurs pour faire
découvrir du savoir faire et à ce moment
là faut s'organiser parce que comme tout
comme tous secteurs on a vu les ravages
que peut faire le tourisme dans certains
secteurs et le but du jeu c'est de
préserver aussi ce pourquoi les gens
viennent les choses qui vont voir donc
ça c'est très important de se dire que
en accueil du monde il faut préserver
son territoire cette actualité un jour
où les gens viennent découvrir votre
village
c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire au mieux
préparer au mieux en tout cas c'est sûr
denis thomas voilà quand les
collectivités elles réfléchissent à
comment on aménage le territoire comment
on fait ça il faut y penser aux 6 à 7
nouvelles populations qu'on fait venir
finalement mais il faut préparer le
monde viticole à les accueillir
celui dont on peut citer plusieurs
exemples le premier la route des grands
crus la route des grands crus qui est
qui qui façonne ses paysages magnifiques
et évidemment le les exploitations ont
évolué mais le vignoble a évolué et il a
été maîtrisé
il a été maîtrisé aussi par les
nouvelles générations de viticulteurs
mais le dos tourisme c'est aussi un
vecteur de communication c'est un
vecteur aussi économique pour le
territoire
si je prends la véloroute beau naissante
mais alors ça veut dire que il faut que
les vignerons fasse attention à leur
attitude alors pour jouer je vais venir
boudent ce n'est la véloroute bonne
santé la voie des vignes génère un euro
du kilomètre
il est environ soixante mille vélos par
an vous imaginez les retombées
économiques et
l'interprofession et la collectivité que
je représente ont mis en place depuis
une dizaine d'années des stations de
lavage pour récupérer les
phytosanitaires et on récupère entre 60
et 70% d'intrants donc type qui
aujourd'hui sont maîtrisés avant d'être
rejetée dans dans le raisonnement
donc c'est plutôt un engagement de la
collectivité avec des budgets énormes
donc effectivement aujourd'hui on se
rend compte que la profession prend
conscience de ces difficultés et les
collectivités notamment département de
la côte d'or est aux côtés de la
profession alors moi j'ai envie de et en
même temps comme dit un personnage
célèbre en ce moment de retourner aussi
la chose vous parliez de vélo route de
choses comme ça mais à linverse jean
michel aubinel le viticulteur que vous
êtes il sent parfois plus sur son
territoire quand il ya vingt vélos qui
passe dans son dos et qui les lui avec
avec une machine dire que le monde
viticole se sent lui aussi parfois pas
agresser mais
un peu perturbé dans son fonctionnement
il arrive qu'on se sente perturbé il
arrive qui a effectivement de
l'agression verbale presque physique
parfois aussi je crois que moi je
retiens ce que ce que vient de dire
dolly on doit communiquer depuis deux
ans on a organisé un grand nombre de
réunions dans les communes dans les
villages avec l'aide justement des élus
locaux parce qu'ils ont également un
rôle à jouer justement dans cette
communication entre producteurs que nous
sommes et les citoyens qui habitent nos
villages ou qui s'y promènent
mais voilà il faut absolument communiqué
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui
va passer en vélo sur sur la voie verte
nous avons une voie verte à prissé qui
traverse pressé c'est vrai ne comprend
pas nos gestes ne comprend pas nos
pratiques
donc si on ne va pas au devant d'eux
pour leur expliquer effectivement il y
aura toujours cette incompréhension
entre ces deux mondes je vous pose une
question complètement naïve
on supprime les produits chimiques et on
règle nos problèmes on arrête notre
édition elle est volontairement provoqué
en saura un jour dans ce monde
merveilleux je l'espère je le souhaite
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est vous
donner le temps nécessaire pour faire
évoluer nos pratiques pour les adapter
je crois que j'avais amené cette charte
que l'on a écrite
on va y venir effectivement sur les
solutions on va y venir je voulais juste
effectivement qu'on comprenne que il y
avait aussi un ressenti qui fonctionnait
dans les deux sens avec un autre sujet
kevin teyssieu c'est la pression
immobilière aussi parfois c'est à dire
que vous vivez dans le village et puis
vous nous vous ne le dirais aussi les
gens auront envie je le disais en
ouverture les jours ils ont envie de
vivre avec vue sur les vignes
donc ils veulent faire construire des
maisons et quand on fait qu'on sur des
maisons on peut parfois rogner des
terres à vignes en particulier quand
parfois les situations économiques sont
difficiles je pense à une région tout
proche d'ici qu'est le beaujolais par
exemple qui a vécu des situations plus
difficiles salle et vigneron il en parle
aussi de cette pression immobilière je
suppose oui donc c'est nous sommes
pression immobilière qui effectivement
très importante il ya le voilà c'est
vrai que c'est important si aussi cette
image c'est à dire que quand on met moi
je pense je peux en parler parce que je
suis je viens de lyon donc on a cette
image un peu bucolique de la vie en se
disant bon allez on va s'installer dans
les vies ça sympa
une super belle vue sont sans prendre
conscience qu effectivement bas il ya un
travail derrière et des pratiques et que
meilleur moyen de toute manière et ça
reste c'est sp communication c'est de
comprendre le territoire dans lequel on
va s'installer et c'est pas de le
prendre simplement comme un produit un
service se dire comment je matin grossi
dans ce territoire là ce territoire là
et comment je peux arriver à communiquer
échanger avec les professionnels qui
sont autour
marie pasquet elle un communiqué journée
je suis tout à fait pour mais faut se
dire aussi qu'il ya de plus en plus de
gens qu'ils renoncent à venir dans le
vignoble puisque maintenant les
problèmes sont connus
donc c'est vrai que ce vivre ensemble il
est très important mais je crois que si
on veut que les villages ne soit pas
constitué uniquement de viticulteurs il
faut maintenant c'est quand même plutôt
le contraire actuelle en rond quand on
est un village comme pressée par exemple
on voit que beaucoup de gens qui
viennent de mâcon pour pour vivre ici je
sais pas si c'est la tendance
moi je sais que dans les adhérents ou
dans les gens qui me contacte il ya des
gens qui me disent ben voilà on aimerait
s'installer à virer c'est à côté d'une
parcelle de vigne c'est en bio qu'est ce
que vous en pensez et puis on a beaucoup
qui renoncent en fait qu'ils se disent
que ça va être trop compliqué moi je
trouve que c'est dommage qu'on donne
encore des permis de construire dans des
zones qui sont à côté de parcelles
parce que maintenant on connaît les
problèmes et je trouve que c'est
vraiment un problème c'est parler de
construire denis thomas c'est une
solution sa limite et les permis de
construire faire attention par azalées
on peut remarquer que dans les villages
viticoles c'est déjà préservée l'étendue
des permis de construire puisque le
village par le territoire est déjà
protégée par le vignoble déjà ses
premiers points
donc il n'y a pas forcément de
développement des communes
je rappelle aussi que il ya une
concentration sur les villes d
agglomération aujourd'hui les métropoles
grossistes tous les jours donc les
villages ruraux ont toute leur
pertinence à condition évidemment de
maîtriser
les l'environnement et je crois qu on
est plutôt dans cette voie là alors on a
essayé d'identifier un petit peu les
situations la solution les solutions
c'est quoi alors vous nous dites faut se
parler
alors d'abord est ce que kevin terrieux
forcément est ce qu'une saint vincent
tournante avec des professionnels du
monde viticole et des habitants de la
commune c'est une une amorce de solution
la solution oui c'est moi je pense qu'il
ya il ya une chose dont on n'a pas parlé
et justement en prendre en prenant un
peu de recul c'est sûr largement de
développement duras et c'est sur cet
aspect social et ses stades et cohésion
c'est d'essayer de traiter la
problématique pas forcément
confrontation mais d'essayer de se dire
que il faut trouver des moyens comme
aujourd'hui pour essayer de faire
travailler des personnes entre elles les
personnes qui sont du monde viticole et
pas du monde viticole pour trouver ces
ces prétextes à communiqué aborder ces
sujets et les amener doucement sur la
table pour éviter que ce soit trop
brutale et un an et demi de travail avec
au final 600 bénévoles aujourd'hui donc
30% qui sont pas de la profession c'est
une opportunité d'amorcer un dialogue
alors on va pas commencer à parler de
ces sujets là mais au final peut-être
dans un an deux ans on va se retrouver
autour de la table pour traiter de ces
sujets là et on a revécu un événement et
finalement ce lien social aura servi à
serrer une problématique technique et
racj avait effectivement répondre à un
défi qui est aujourd'hui portée à la
profession mais à beaucoup d'autres
professions oui voilà on parle du monde
viticole ça concerne aussi le monde
agricole dans son ensemble en c est ce
que c'est un sujet politique au sens
étymologique du terme c'est à dire dans
la vie de la cité
denis thomas c'est le rôle des élus
aussi faire fonctionner des conseils
municipaux de 1 d'intégrer dans les
listes municipales peut-être des
villages viticoles des gens qui sont pas
issus forcément de monde viticole
alors que dans certains villages on sait
que c'était un peu de choses près
préempter on va dire par les forces
économiques du village dont globalement
monde viticole oui il faut que ça change
et il faut que ça peut jouer un rôle
écoutez moi je suis plutôt partisan de
d'avoir des déséquilibres que les
professions soit représentée au sein des
conseillers municipaux municipaux
effectivement la viticulture a toute sa
place
les ruraux ont leur place les les
professions qui sont extérieurs au monde
viticole ont leur place je crois que une
collectivité et les gens y vivent a
guidé qui vivent et travaillent ailleurs
parce que c'est aussi ça qui a beaucoup
changé dans l'est c'est une question que
tout le monde se pose aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on voit bien sur des domaines
viticoles ou les les employés des
domaines viva la ville et reviennent le
matin travaillé sur le domaine donc ne
vivent plus dans le dans dans le village
intra muros et ça c'est une difficulté
aujourd'hui de maîtriser l'immobilier et
au lieu de construire proche des vignes
bien on pourrait avoir des leviers qui
permettent de réhabiliter notamment le
patrimoine rural le patrimoine intérieur
des villages qui se vide et c'est une
façon aussi de d'intégrer ces nouveaux
habitants
marine parce que la dimension politique
l'entrée dans les conseils municipaux
par exemple c'est une solution votre
point de vue oui je pense que c'est ça
peut être une solution
après c'est vrai que le travail des
associations même si les gens qui les
constituent vous font pas forcément
partie d'instance ne seront pas
forcément ému le travail est quand même
assez remarquable on n'est pas les seuls
il ya plusieurs associations comme la
nôtre et puis savent faire sacrer aussi
du lien social et on rencontre les élus
sans forcément être élu nous mêmes
alors justement vous parlez du travail
des associations avec les instances en
revenant à notre point de départ qui
étaient ces menaces dans le mâconnais en
mâconnais vous avez vous en parliez jean
michel aubinel élaborer une charte de
bonnes pratiques viticoles heures à
proximité des établissements sensibles
c'est ça c'est l'intitulé on signale
d'ailleurs que les coopératives du jura
sont dans le dans l'accord je crois je
le dis puisque notre émission et sur la
bourgogne et sur la franche-comté donc
ça c'est important de le dire est ce que
c'est bien est-ce que vous alors est ce
que c'est bien ce que c'est suffisant il
faut aller plus loin
vous allez me dire tout ça un petit mot
jean michel aubinel d'abord de sept
chars oui alors nous avions déjà signé
une charte départementale et qui
englober l'ensemble du monde agricole
puisqu'il ya pas que la viticulture on
avait dit qui est concerné par ces
problématiques
aujourd'hui nous avons écrit une charte
au niveau régional
donc cette charte qu'est ce qu'elle dit
un autre façon simple qu'est ce qu'elle
dit le titre est très simple engager nos
terroirs dans nos territoires
ça veut tout dire ça veut dire
qu'effectivement nous sommes sur nos
terroirs
nous travaillons nos terroirs mais par
contre font partie d'un ensemble migros
et est donc gré et donc vous vous faites
attention à quoi concrètement ça veut
dire cette charte d'engager l'ensemble
des producteurs l'ensemble des
viticulteurs dans l'évolution justement
de leur pratique elle elle donne des
échéances également alors c'est vrai que
certains nous ont fait le reproche une
charte une charte
voilà oui l'engagement dans une charte
je dirais que c'est incitatif c'est un
impératif
c'est une question c'est pas une un
jugement de valeur c'est juste une
question pour les gens qui nous
regardent comprenne bien
effectivement contrairement à une loi
qui elle impose je dirais qu'une charte
engage et le travail qui a été réalisé
il a fallu un peu plus d'un an de
travail en travaillons également avec
l'amour quand je parle de l'amour ce
sont les fabricants de produit puisqu'on
utilise des produits effectivement ce
sont les fabricants de produits ce sont
les fabricants de matériel de
pulvérisation en travaillant avec
l'amour et surtout on travaille on
auprès de l'ensemble des producteurs
parce que évidemment il faut bien que
l'on communique également en interne
pour qu'on réussisse à faire évoluer ses
pratiques
donc cette charte aujourd'hui un langage
véritablement le vignoble
c'est un engagement vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble de la société
je dirais que ça fait partie de notre
devoir aujourd'hui ont donc validé
concrètement parce que vous ne vous
l'avez toujours pas dit c'est quoi
on ne traite pas autour de 2 des espaces
dits sensibles
c'est quoi des écoles avant d'aller
répondre c'est bien évidemment d'aller
le plus rapidement possible vers
l'utilisation de moins en moins
importantes de pesticides
moi je dirais de produits
phytosanitaires donc y aller le plus
rapidement possible c'est pour ça que je
parle déchéance c'est également revoir
certaines pratiques revoir également nos
matériels etc
donc je dirais c'est ça c'est du concret
on le fait déjà et on sera de plus
amples et les ailes et elle est
appliquée pour l'instant elle commence à
s'appliquer bien évidemment mais je
dirais qu'il ya également des
producteurs qui sont en avance et qui
n'ont pas attendu qu'on écrive une
charte pour améliorer leur pratique
justement marine parce qu'il est
plaisante je vous voyais faire une
grimace à un moment donné c'est pas pour
vous c'est bien pas suffisant peut mieux
faire c'est quoi oui alors c'est quand
même une charte qui va dans le bon sens
faut le reconnaître est là mérite
d'exister après la première critique
qu'on a élaboré nous c'est de ne pas
avoir été conviée à sa rédaction
on aurait quand même aimé voilà être
invité au moins pour pour qu'on entende
nos propositions
sinon oui on trouve qu'elles devraient
aller beaucoup plus loin notamment dans
toutes les zones qui sont proches des
habitations et puis je veux dire pas
uniquement des zones sensibles 106 pts à
dire mais oui voilà déjà les riffs parce
que c'est vrai que ce serait jouable ça
jean michel aubinel sur l'aspect en
allant de répondre à leur travail commun
déjà
ouais parce qu'on dit on parle de vivre
ensemble depuis tout à l'heure donc ce
sera une piste je suppose
alors moi je viendrai sur l'aspect de
proximité de vignes et d'habitation est
par exemple
bon bien évidemment déjà on a mis des
hommes et ce qu'on appelle des identités
des zones de non traitement
autour d'eux des endroits sensibles dans
les écoles les maisons de retraite et
ses dizaines d'autres et non pour tous
les produits uniquement pour les cmr
cancérogènes mutagènes reprotoxiques
pour tous les produits mais c'est pas
appliquée aujourd'hui ces zones soient
appliquées que l'on voudrait éviter
c'est que l'on fixe des zones montjean
qu'ils ont entendu parler par exemple
d'une zone de non traitement de 100 m le
long des voies vertes
si on prend le village de pisser c'est
quelques dizaines d'hectares qui sont
arrachés que l'on va en tirer quelque
part de l'économie
donc en plus les mises souvent les
meilleures photos etc
là effectivement il faut qu'on puisse
évoluer mais là aussi dans la
compréhension et encore une fois en se
laissant et les autres le temps de
s'adapter le temps d'évoluer ça c'est
vraiment important
doni doni thomas jeu je vous je
confisque pas la parole on se déplace un
peu aussi vers la côte d'or avec des
messieurs denis thomas c'est un problème
national en réalité oui effectivement
c'est un problème national on a bien
compris que les médias
les hommes publics la profession les
interprofessions évidemment prennent
prenne en compte toutes ces difficultés
moi je voudrais revenir sur sur des
phénomènes concret vous parliez qu'est
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui le monde
viticole notamment en désherber dans les
vies non avec des produits aujourd'hui
ils reviennent au l'amour donc ça c'est
déjà des évolutions on revient on
revient à des méthodes culturales
historique
donc ça c'est plutôt c'est plutôt
flatteur et c'est plutôt encourageant
ensuite vous avez le département de la
côte d'or qui va proposer au mois de
mars prochain à l'assemblée
le réglage des pulvérisateurs c'est à
dire qu'on va régler à minima pour
éviter est justement d'avoir de fortes
de fortes pressions concernant les
traitements dont vous voyez ça c'est des
éléments que les collectivités peuvent
porter également de l'une des cieux on
voit que c'est compliqué quand même
c'est à dire qu'une fois qu'on a dit il
faut qu'on améliore et qu'on vive
ensemble c'est compliqué quand même
alors c'est compliqué mais je reviens
toujours à cette notion plus largement
développement durable en se disant mais
c'est c'est un système c'est à dire que
si on aborde une problématique juste
cette problématique là sont sans prendre
en compte qu'effectivement bas il ya des
liens partout on parler d'économie en
parlait trop du phytosanitaires ont
parlé de beaucoup de choses
et finalement dans le secteur viticole
tout le monde a envie d'avancer dans la
même direction mais envie de préserver
cet équilibre là pour faire en sorte que
l'entreprise soit pérenne de préserver
aussi ses salariés la thématique sociale
et la d'avancer de progresser continuer
à exporter de proposer des reins faire
valoir son savoir faire et en même temps
arrivées à traiter ces problématiques
donc c'est pas évident c'est sûr que
forcément il ya une marche une marge de
progression qui est là mais il ya une
vraie volonté
il ya une vraie volonté aussi la
génération qui arrive à alors là c'est
ce que j'allais vous demandez ce qu'est
une dimension générationnelle dans tout
ça aussi on peut pas peut pas dire que
je vais pas vous dire que génération de
mes parents étaient sensibilisés mais
quelque part la nôtre les beaucoup plus
ça c'est clair sensibiliser sur cette
notion de développement durable
ça veut dire quand on arrive en
entreprise quand on arrive dans les
exploitations
eh bien on a cette thématique là qui
arrivent et donc on n'est pas surpris
de devoir travailler sur sur ces
tensions là la tendance c'est quoi est
ce que vous êtes
les uns et les autres optimiste est-ce
que l'on réalité quelques choses
s'enclenchent où vous avez encore des
doutes marine pasquier on sent que voilà
c'est ça avance mais ça avance doucement
mais je dirais les deux mois je suis
fondamentalement optimiste sinon je
serai pas président de l'association ça
c'est une amorce voilà il ya un début
d'amore on va dire mais il ya énormément
énormément le travail encore qu'il reste
à faire et on comprend que vous regardez
ailleurs vous avec d'autres associations
en france tous à se croiser en ce moment
oui oui on travaille avec une
association équivalente à la nôtre en
gironde on travaille aussi avec des
associations c'est que le sujet n'y a
pas à dire dans la zone bordelaise en
particulier oui et puis au niveau
national il ya quand même des rapports
qui est sorti au mois de décembre de 10
g est ex générale des affaires sociales
là dessus par exemple sur les pesticides
il ya une loi qui va être votée au sénat
enfin projet de loi vendredi sur
l'indemnisation des victimes est là pour
la première fois on parle de victimes
qui sont pas simplement professionnel on
parle aussi de vivre d'accord jean
michel aubinel optimiste ou pessimiste
je suis de nature optimiste
il est tout ça j'en parle de génération
oui parce qu'aujourd'hui un jeune
viticulteur qui s'installent quelque
vingt ans où quelqu'un plus âgées comme
moi on est quand même tous sensibilisés
on parle les jours de réchauffement
climatique etc
donc je crois que effectivement des
jeunes plus fort mais évolueront plus
rapidement dans leurs pratiques
c'est par contre on est tous concernés
ont cependant seront tous encore une
fois motivé pour évoluer
dommage je crois que encore une fois si
on arrive à continuer de se rencontrer
de discuter de s'expliquer de sa prendre
mutuellement ce que l'on attend de ce
que l'on veut je crois que nous avons
fait des progrès et moi je suis
optimiste parce que cette volonté est
partagée
eh bien écoutez c'est une belle une
belle conclusion pour notre émission
merci à tous les quatre d'être d'être
venus échanger sur ce sujet profitez
bien de cette 536 dossiers jusqu'à ce
soir bon courage
kevin teyssieu pour la fin de cette
salle un sens et puis sur france 3
rester avec nous après le 12 13
c'est là vous proposera une balade au
coeur du morvan avec gaël grand don
merci à tous bon dimanche et au revoir
merci au monde
[Musique]